l'utilisation des sous-produits de
l'huile de palme dans la ration des
vaches a fait couler beaucoup d'encre
cet hiver plusieurs ont été étonnés
d'apprendre que cet aliment contreversé
associée notamment à la déforestation en
asie du sud est était donnée à des
vaches laitières ici deux mois après que
les producteurs laitiers du canada ait
demandé à leurs membres d'envisager de
manière volontaire 10 alternative à ces
suppléments vous faisons le point sur la
situation
[Musique]
la ferme vite et kint à delta dans l'est
de l'ontario elle a été fondée par le
père d'éric barrowman arrivée
d'allemagne en 1982
aujourd'hui elle compte 40 vaches dieuze
et en lactation et les barmans nous
montre ce que mange son troupeau
les six à toi le ration finale pour la
vache alors cela c'est tout mélanger et
dans la main gauche ici on à l'acide
palmitique c'est des gens dans la ration
finale chaque jour une jo dimanche 20 kg
de matière sèche principalement de
l'ensilage de maïs de soya et de foin et
depuis quatre ans éric barman ajoute une
petite quantité d'acide palmitique à la
ration ici en en grammes par jour par
vache s'est pas beaucoup ça correspond à
0,5 pour cent de ce qu'elle mange
c'est pas une source primaire de la
ration c'est juste quelque chose pour
aider leurs performances
eric baumann et étudiant au doctorat en
nutrition animale
c'est lors d'un projet de recherche
qu'ils constatent l'impact y supplément
d'huile de palme sur l'iph h ici pour
nous je trouve que ça au mans le teneur
de groupe par environ 0 point important
ces produits ne sont pas bon marché mais
ils sont rentables à la firme vittek int
chaque dollar investi en suppléments
d'acide palmitique en rapportera 3 ce
qui se traduit par quelques milliers de
dollars de plus à la fin de la nuit le
taux de gras dans le lait c'est
important premièrement parce que la pays
pour le gros et si on a une supplément
qui va monter le teneur de grodd la
vache les mêmes vache peut livrer plus
de kilos de grains laitière par jour
c'est à dire que on rend les lâche plus
efficace est temps que ce produit sera
approuvé par santé canada comme c'est
toujours le cas et les barmans n'a pas
l'intention d'arrêter d'en donner
je suis producteur mais aussi je suis
consommateur nous dans ma famille en
bois nollet à chaque jour je vais pas
mettre quelque chose dans la ration des
vaches où je suis pas certain que c'est
bon pour les vaches ou pour les humains
la nouvelle tartinades aux noisettes de
kraft est fait
sans huile de palme sauf que c'est un
produit avec lequel plusieurs prennent
leurs distances
sa production est synonyme de
déforestation et de destruction
d'habitats pour plusieurs espèces
menacées sans compter le fait que plus
d'un million d'enfants travaillent dans
les palmeraies en asie du sud est
utilisé dans les aliments transformés
les cosmétiques les biocarburants la
peinture huile de palme a vu sa
production mondiale multiplié par cinq
depuis 1995 au canada depuis 2007 les
importations d'huile de palme ont
augmenté de 400% cet immense popularité
s'explique entre autres par les
rendements exceptionnels de cette
culture pour produire la même quantité
d'huile de soja de tournesol ou de
canola il faudrait jusqu'à neuf fois
plus de terres opté pour une autre huile
aurait aussi des conséquences sur
l'environnement
mais pourrait-on même remplacer l'huile
de palme très digeste pour la vache par
une huile produite localement
pas si simple selon cette spécialiste de
la nutrition animale
ce serait une façon par exemple de
données de l'huile de tournesol l'huile
de maïs d'enrichir la densité
énergétique la ration de l'animal par
contre le rumen vont souffrir elle nous
explique que deux raisons motivent
l'ajout de suppléments d'huile de palme
pour augmenter le taux de gras tout au
long de la lactation comme chez eric
baumann et pour aider la vache
particulièrement en début de lactation
faut comprendre que ces animaux leurs
bases d'un état où ils produisent faude
les quelques semaines plus tard ils vont
produire 50 kg de lait qui contient à
peu près 4% m/m +2 4% drôle 50 kg
équivalent grosso modo à 50 litres se
séparent jour hawks et énormément
d'énergie ou faut augmenter la densité
énergétique de la ration notre animal
puis en illimité par les ingrédients
qu'on peut utiliser donc une bonne façon
d'augmenter l'énergie c'est vrai pour
les humains aussi c'est de donner des
lipides
si on a aujourd'hui recours au
supplément de gras comme l'huile de
palme c'est entre autres parce qu'au fil
du temps on a sélectionné les vaches
pour qu'elle soit toujours plus
productive pour nourrir son petit une
vache n'a besoin que de 8 litres de lait
par jour alors qu en production laitière
elle peut en livrer plus de 60
au début de la lactation de l'animal des
besoins énergétiques qui surpasse sa
capacité d'ingestion augmenter la
densité énergétique
en d'autres mots la vache n'a pas assez
de places dans ces estomac pour contenir
toute la nourriture nécessaires à une
production intensive de l'est il faut
donc ajouter des suppléments riche en
énergie souvent je m'amuse à les
comparer à des athlètes olympiques de
haut niveau là on nous répond à un
athlète olympique avec de la salade
feixes c'est des animaux qui ont des
grands grands besoins énergétiques
et comme les athlètes olympiques leur
carrière est courte au canada à peine la
moitié des vaches survivent à leur
troisième village alors qu'elle aurait
le potentiel de vivre beaucoup plus
longtemps en 2018 est un sondage des
producteurs de lait du québec révélait
que 22 % d'entre eux utilisaient des
suppléments d'huile de palme en ontario
et dans les provinces de l'ouest cette
proportion serait de 55 %
la pratique a cours depuis des décennies
dans le monde laitier mais c'est que cet
hiver que le grand public en a pris
connaissance
alors que les gens sont confinées à la
maison et cuisine plus qu'à l'habitude
certains remarquent que le beurre serait
peut-être plus dur qu'avant les
suppléments d'acide palmitique sont
soudainement montré du doigt
à l'université guelph le chercheur
alejandro marangoni a analysé 50 marques
différentes de beurre ils constatent une
corrélation plus le beurre contient de
l'acide palmitique un acide gras qui est
solide à la température de la pièce plus
il est dur l'huile de palme est sans
danger pour les vaches
il fournit l'énergie dont ils ont besoin
pour l'énorme quantité de lait produites
quotidiennement le lait d'une vache qui
ne mangent que du fourrage contiendra
quand même de l'acide palmitique c'est
naturel mais si on ajoute des
suppléments à la ration il en contiendra
plus ce qui se passe et la littérature
scientifique il avait déjà décrit c'est
qu'en ajoutant des suppléments la ration
des animaux le beurre est plus riche en
acide palmitique est aussi plus dur si
ces analyses donnent un aperçu de la
situation actuelle pour le beurre le
professeur marangoni ne peut pas
conclure que les vaches mangent plus
d'acide palmitique qu'avant parce qu'il
n'existe aucune donnée historique
d'autres facteurs comme des changements
de procéder en usine pourrait aussi
influencer la dureté du beurre
les producteurs de lin tiennent à le
préciser ce qu'ils utilisent c'est un
résidu de l'extraction de l'huile de
palme chez éric barman il est certifié
de sources durables
je pense c'est une question plus globale
et a toujours demande pour les produits
moins chers les demandes pour lui le
peuple c'est paul là à cause des
producteurs laitiers
c'est bien de là consommateur qui veut
lui il parle dans ses galons au bar dont
ces biscuits d'un savant dans les
cosmétiques
aujourd'hui on estime que près de 50%
des aliments emballés contiendrait de
l'huile de palme sont réellement de
toute cette nourriture bon marché
produite à n'importe quel prix l'huile
de palme en est un excellent exemple
c'est lui la moins chère sur la planète
produit au détriment des forêts vierges
et des animaux sommes nous prêts à payer
plus en fait ces produits le s qui sont
indispensables
certainement puisque c'est pas tous les
produits par qui n'utilisent puis
les vaches réussissent quand même a très
bien performé et le pays qui en a fait
la preuve c'est la suisse
[Musique]
en 2017
un reportage à la télé suisse allemande
révèle la présence de suppléments
d'huile de palme dans la ration des
vaches
le public est choqué un an plus tard les
producteurs suisses abandonnent les
sous-produits d'huile de palme
[Musique]
l'utilisation d'une huile produite à des
milliers de kilomètres dans des
conditions qui ne correspondent pas
toujours à nos valeurs soulève de vastes
questions est ce qu'on souhaite une
efficacité maximale à moindre coût et
des volumes toujours plus grand où on
commence à prendre en considération les
pratiques durables et la santé animale
dans la production alimentaire je ne
veux pas montrer du doigt les
consommateurs parce que c'est notre
affaire à tous est fou le sujet est
complexe et si les impacts de la
production d'huile de palme sur les
forêts et la faune nous inquiète
il faut il travailler ensemble tieger
on commence par bannir l'utilisation
d'un sous-produit on ne s'attaque pas
aux vrais problèmes
[Musique]
m